how should a writer begin a movie
a writer should begin a movie with an
event that captures your attention
um it could be something audacious it
could be with a car exploding
it could be with uh an interaction
between two people
that is a major interaction for their
relationship
um it could it's it needs to start with
something that upends the world of the
character that you're following
and i think from there everything sort
of goes
smoothly from there if you start with
that and thinking of
an older movie um sunset boulevard and
how the movie is essentially bookended
by the same thing happening but you you
see the consequence
you see the ending in the beginning and
then i find that very interesting
because then you're piecing together
well how did how did this happen i mean
you know the screenwriter seems so nice
like what what happened who was it you
know
right right yeah i mean so many movies
are like that you know you start a film
with a murder and then it's like okay
that's important
but now we get to see how it all came
together and why it happened
yeah right and so what about the use of
too much conflict
in the beginning or is there no such
thing honestly i don't think there is
such a thing as too much conflict um i
think there can be
conflict that takes away from the main
storyline
that's something but i think in general
the more you have characters with
opposing world views and opposing goals
i think the stronger the film becomes
and that was something that was
something i learned after rising star
my my two lead characters they had one
major
difference of opinion and that sort of
drove the film
but there wasn't enough there needed to
be more
and that that was something like when i
got into csun
i i could see it in my own writing and
the stuff that i wrote after that i
really made it a point
from the very beginning there needs to
be something
you know that's that's talked about and
or that's
seen you know between characters where
there's problems
because the problems are where the
conflict come from and the stories where
the conflict the the
the story is ultimately what comes from
that's how that deal with it we see that
too in uh documentaries don't we where
there's there's kind of like a conflict
or there's the tension of kind of what
happened
in the very beginning of the film and
then it goes back
oh very yeah very common which part of
the screenwriting process is
most difficult for you i think the
revisions
are the hardest part for me um i've
generally been
pretty good at being able to write a
first draft of something
because of my background as a journalist
i'm used to just
kind of spitting out thoughts and just
kind of getting them out very quickly
so i can write a first draft usually
with pretty quickly it's when
you finish that draft and you have that
moment
of oh my god this is so great i just
finished this
and then that thought turns into but you
know this needs to get fixed
and going back over and finding the
moments that don't work
and introducing theme and you know
strengthening supporting characters and
things like that and making every
character integral to the storyline and
cutting characters that you don't need
all of those things are tough for me
because
now the way that i write i try to
outline as much as i can
before i start so when i have that first
draft i think well this is actually
really a second or third
draft because i did all this outlining
work so this must be much closer to
finishing
you know than it would be and then i
read it and then i realized it's not
and really kind of bearing down and
doing that really fine work
of you know cutting the the sentence of
dialogue that you don't need
um you know finding a way to get rid of
the widow so you have one line of action
instead of two you know those those
kinds of things
that takes me a lot of time um so
i think that would be the hardest thing
for me do you
do you do the whole like put it in a
drawer from you know the cliche
put it away for a month or no sometimes
uh it depends on the story like i have i
have one script i've been working on it
for
gosh i think seven years now and i'll
write a draft
i'll put it away i'll go do something
else i'll come back to it
i think i'm on draft eight right now and
it's taking a long time and it's it's
changed quite a bit
from what it originally was and i think
it's still going to
change because i started writing it so
far before i went to school
now i look at it and i say okay now
there's some really big things i can
change
and this that would make it a lot better
so yeah i mean sometimes
sometimes i put it away for a little bit
and sometimes i put it away for a really
long time
it sounds like that script means a lot
to you um or it's just something
it's it's something that i know if i do
it right
could really help me in my career so
for that particular script i want to
make sure that when the world sees it
it's as good as it can possibly be
because every time i've pitched it
people love the idea literally every
single time i have yet to have a
negative reaction to this
so my response to that is okay i'm gonna
sit on this and i'm gonna make sure
that when it does go out into the world
it's ready and it's there's not a word
out of place
so there's still a ways to go before i
get to that but
it's getting there in your mind marty
what's the purpose of story
i think story exists to remind people
that we're not alone
every time i see a film that really
connects with me
i always think that okay someone else is
dealing with something similar to what i
am
um or someone's thought you know a way
about life
the same way that i have um you know
story is
is a way to build community uh and
that's something
that connects not only to the the film
that you watch
but also the way that you make it you
know so much of of indie filmmaking now
is
is about community building um but in
terms of
you know the story itself it's it's a
way for people to
to realize that they're in a lot of ways
we're all the same
do you think that's why it's a richer
experience seeing it in a theater
i think so i in in certain ways
i think i think you get more out of
seeing uh
like a real good drama or real good
comedy with an audience
um well let's let me rephrase that
yeah i think i think seeing a film in a
theater is a really powerful way to
connect with that community like i still
remember
in 1999 i think when
there's something about mary came out i
was living in florida and
i went to go see that in the theater and
to this day i have never laughed so hard
in a movie
and part of it was because everybody
else was laughing just as hard
so that was just an amazing experience
um when the south park movie came out i
think it was that same year the year
before
i remember that there were people
standing up and cheering
you know at parts of that film like it
was it was just really
it was hilarious and it was it was
cathartic
you know for everybody that was in there
just a chance to really have a good
laugh
um yeah you know and you can it carries
all the way to this day i saw a film
called the farewell
uh last week at the alamo drafthouse and
that film was just a beautiful story
about a chinese family
and how the american member of that
family has to go over to china
and deal with a family problem there and
it was even though it was
about a chinese family it was universal
because the drama within the family is
something that
so many people know and in that
experience
being in that theater and it was a
packed theater it was great like the
moments of pathos were strong the
moments of humor were strong
and at the end of the film you know
people were talking about it like i was
talking with the folks that we were
sitting next to and
you know have never met them before and
you know here we are with the shared
experience you know
it's something you know the netflix's
and amazons of the world are going to be
here forever
but there is still something really
special about seeing a film in a theater
there really is and it's nice when you
can just turn to the person next to you
afterward and just
or even just seeing the sort of the
demeanor of people
leaving the theater you know because
there is in la it is tough with like
there's this whole new cell phone
etiquette that a lot of people just
don't
sort of regard so there's that part but
once that's all over and everybody kind
of puts the phone away hopefully
then then you know we get to this part
where you can really see
is it affecting people and it's
interesting when
you're laughing at a part that other
people aren't sometimes i wonder are
they just restraining
themselves or you hear sort of moments
of shock there's been
films and i won't go into them what they
are because they're very political
but where you can tell you can see the
outrage
just by a gasp from from someone but you
know what that's another part of the
experience
you know the the community aspect
doesn't always have to be positive
i i saw uh when fahrenheit 911 came out
i saw that in the theater and people
broke out into
yelling matches after the fight was done
wow
and to me that was wonderful
because yes it's stressful because
obviously people
with with different beliefs are going to
be very vocal about them and thankfully
it didn't devolve into an actual
physical
altercation but that that's the power of
movies
that's the power of cinema is to to get
people
emotionally engaged and whether you're
on the same side
or if you're on different sides it's the
engagement that's the most important
thing
and so obviously i'm on one side of that
for that particular film
and there were folks that i was
supportive of in that yelling match
but you know the fact that we were
involved that's
why that film was made was to generate
discussion was to to generate
not controversy but although of course
it had it but
you know get people talking and so that
film
did its job you know in that particular
screening
so and i think i think that's what
filmmakers should shoot for is that
level of engagement you know in whatever
form
whether it's communal or whether it's in
the moment divisive i think either one
is is totally valid where was this
uh this was in connecticut yeah and this
was after the screening
yeah yeah and did just curious we'll
move on but did security or ushers have
to come in
there were folks watching but like no
one you know no one actually threw a
punch or anything like that
so there was it just sort of it happened
they yelled and then everyone just kind
of went their separate ways
so to me and i know a lot of people
won't say this but
i look at that as a positive because
everybody gets a chance to kind of get
their views out
and you know it makes people a little
uncomfortable for the moment but
do you want that or do you want people
sitting and stewing you know
right and the one i'm thinking of which
was more recent
i usually like to clap after films and
i'm always amazed
when people don't but um no one wanted
to clap after this film
so i was like i think maybe i'll just
keep my my clapping to myself
okay all right i don't want to be
outnumbered here so yeah
you